very grateful to have Mike star here
from Facebook he's gonna be talking
about data storm so he uses all kinds of
different data analytics to get insights
into existing products and drive
development of new products so let's
just have him talk about data storm and
how he leverages this big data thank you
thank you okay
can everyone hear me everyone in the
back okay my name is Mike Starr I work
here at Facebook so I hope you guys have
enjoyed our campus so far and I work
inside of an organization at Facebook we
call data infrastructure so I am NOT a
data scientist but I build tools which
enable data scientists to do cool things
today I'm going to talk to you about a
system that we have internally here at
Facebook it's a system we call data
swarm if you saw the previous talks by
the parsley guys this is the batch batch
processing equivalent of their streaming
pipeline or maybe you saw the previous
talk by stripe they use a system from
Spotify called Luigi this is our
equivalent to Luigi but yeah if Burke if
you saw Burke's keynote yesterday this
talk may be more aptly named how to move
300 petabytes of data so let's get
started I'm gonna start by telling you
about one of my friends who works here
at Facebook his name is Neil so Neil is
a data engineer which means that Neil
does looks at Facebook's data and tries
to find useful interesting stuff right
so a couple months ago Neil and his team
started working on this new machine
learning project that they wanted to do
and it had a structure that kind of
follows this dag like thing and for the
rest of the talk I'm going to refer to
any dag where you have tasks doing stuff
and dependencies between those tasks as
a data pipeline so Neil needed to build
a data pipeline to do something right
and at first Neil and his team thought
about building a custom solution built
off 0 mq so here's what happened Neil is
a data engineer who found himself facing
a lot of non dent data engineering
things so Neil had to think about
scheduling how do I make sure that my
machine learning
pipeline is gonna run every single day
you had to think about things like
dependencies so how do i coordinate asks
so that one task will only start after
another one is complete
and then finally neal had to deal with
things like fault tolerance for when you
know stages of your pipeline eventually
do fail do you know what Neal wasn't
thinking about at this point he wasn't
thinking about number one which is
machine learning so why is it that Neal
who's a data engineer is thinking about
so many non data engineering things so I
argue that it doesn't have to be this
way I think that Neal should do machine
learning and I also argue that data
scientists should focus on data science
it seems really straightforward but this
is actually like it is it seems crazy
right it that's that should be the way
people work but it's not not in not in
reality in reality data scientists do a
lot more than just data scientists they
write a lot of software they write a lot
of software that isn't about data
science but it's about launching their
data science and doing you know it's
harnessing those applications they also
have to deal with things like deployment
right so you wrote this awesome great
software suite which is gonna run some
pandas thing or some numpy or psych it
and you got to get it out into
production and running out a bunch of
machines and then finally once you do
have it deployed you've got to make sure
that it keeps running every single day
right and that sucks it sucks that our
days data scientists have to think about
this but I argue that it doesn't have to
be that way I argue that data's data
scientists can spend their days working
on data science they just need a little
bit of help and here at Facebook that
help comes from a tool we call data
swarming so what is data swarm data
swarm at a high level is the tool which
enables data scientists to convert raw
log data into useful information it's
the glue which ties together a bunch of
different data processing systems the
main one here at Facebook being hive and
coordinates those systems in such a way
that useful stuff pops out the other end
data swarm is not a data engine it's not
a database it doesn't do any of the
heavy lifting itself
it directs other systems and tells them
what to do instead this is just like a
high-level at Facebook how data enters
the system and flows through for data
for batch processing so it all begins
with a person like you guys doing
something on Facebook right you like you
like the PI data conference page or
something like that that action leads to
a web request on our back-end servers
and those web requests then might
generate a bunch of log events these are
not just printf to the console they're
they're structured log events which have
certain meaning and those log events are
sent out through a system called scribe
and then eventually loaded into our data
warehouse and that's where Neal comes in
yeah yeah Thank You Neal for letting me
use your fixture you're a good sport so
Neal Neal comes in and then this where
he decides he's gonna do some crazy [ __ ]
with zero I'm Q but maybe he shouldn't
right he's got to do something else um
and that's where we're data's form fits
into the picture so to motivate this
example we're gonna do one of my
favorite things to do at Facebook and
that's find cat gifs so we're gonna
write a dummy pipeline both with and
without data swarm and the pipeline it's
gonna find the top 10 cat gifs shared on
Facebook yesterday and then we're gonna
try and post them to a group so that we
can collect a bunch of likes from our
peers and be awesome like that so how do
we find cat gifs we're gonna break it
down into a three stage pipeline the
first stage is finding cat gifs I'll
leave that to the data scientists in the
room who are way smarter than me to
actually figure out how to find cat gifs
we'll just pretend that we're gonna look
at the URL for jiff and then look at the
title for cat something like that the
next step is to dump those cat gifs to a
file because files are great because you
can run scripts on them and then here at
Facebook we don't use Python for our web
stack we use PHP so we're gonna use some
PHP code to actually post those URLs
directly to a group sound good so here's
a here we go here's the cat jiff finder
post to a group pipeline in regular
Python no data swim it's not too
complicated right we have this function
called fine cat gifs
maybe under the covers that's doing a
subprocess which will run a hive query
or maybe using some connector we have
dump cat gifs again it takes as the
input the output of the previous step
and will dump to a text file and then
finally you've got the post cat gif step
which again maybe would spawn PHP
interpret or in a sub process and then
post the cat gifs to a group scheduling
our pipeline is also pretty
straightforward once we've tested and
make sure it does the thing that we want
to do it we schedule it with cron write
cron is pretty straightforward this this
is just if you've never seen a cron
string this runs something every day at
midnight so life without data swarm is
pretty straightforward and a few simple
lines of code we're able to find and
post cat gifs to a group and you know
we're gonna get likes in no time that's
for sure but this pipeline maybe has
some problems maybe think about it why
would you not want to write pipelines
like this every single day I'll go over
a couple of those reasons why writing
pipelines like this might have issues so
the first thing you want to add to this
pipeline is fault tolerance that's easy
in a non data storm world we're gonna
create some decorator called call with
retries and what does it do it calls
something with retries when it fails
that's easy it's just a couple you know
what extra little decorator but what
happens in reality calling with three
tries doesn't always work right so let's
say we're retrying on a machine but it
hasn't had its type CLI updated in three
months and now it's stopped working I
don't care how many times you try a call
with retries infinity it's not going to
run on that machine
similarly maybe the machine runs out of
disk or maybe the machine just dies
itself right retrying on the same
machine means you're not ready for all
realistic retry scenarios or failures
because the reality of things are that
is is the machine's die right so unless
you're brilliant and ready to retry
things on multiple machines you're not
really ready to handle realistic
failures ok let's talk about another
thing that you might want to do with
this pipeline right so you've already
run the really expensive
cat gifs query so we don't want to run
that step again we commented out and
we're gonna do some work on the dump cat
shift step but we don't want the post
cat jiff step to run also because then
we're gonna annoy all of the people who
are part of our group every time we run
our pipeline we're gonna repost the the
same cat gifs and they're gonna be like
why am I seeing these ten times a day
right so commenting out that works right
everybody's done this everybody has done
this you've commented out code and you
just run parts of the application that
you find interesting what is wrong with
this approach is if you comment the code
out you will never inevitably will
forget to uncomment it and then you have
to revert it goes into production and
now you're feeling pretty dumb because
you've broken your cat gifs pipeline and
then the third thing I'm going to talk
about is remote execution remote
execution again to get it right in this
most basic form is pretty simple we're
gonna define a remote command function
it accepts a command line to run and
then it will SSH to a free machine run
that command and then you can start to
build remote versions of all the things
that you wanted to do so for instance we
could run do remote version of hive and
it will find a find a free machine and
then run a hive query okay so SSH pretty
straightforward what goes wrong here so
this is actually code from data swarm
when I joined Facebook if you if you
can't read it it says do not change
these setting this inappropriately may
bring down data swarm has anyone seen
code like that yeah that kind of code is
scary so and what is it doing it's got
tasks per worker so that's probably how
many commands we want to run on and
forget any given host we've got load
threshold so maybe we don't want to kill
the host by working them too hard and
then we've got buffs threshold so maybe
something with memory right so here's
the funny thing
this code was dead code when I joined
Facebook it didn't do anything but
everyone was so afraid by the comment
that nobody wanted to remove it so the
moral of this story here is that yes
running SSH is is super simple but
running SSH
and in a reliable way when you've got
hundreds of people doing it and machines
dying all the time it gets a lot
trickier so you don't want to build your
own system to handle things like
remoting just SSH use something that
exists so we've talked about three
things that we want to do we want to be
able to handle retries gracefully we
want to be able to selectively run parts
of our pipeline and then finally we want
to be able to run our pipeline over a
bunch of machines well hopefully
somewhere along the lines we we come up
with something more reliable than cron
because again that's not realistic for
scheduling things in production so life
without data swarm is basically this
eternal struggle you're always going to
be fighting against the way that you've
written your pipeline in the first place
so the real problem is you've written in
your pipe on in a way which makes it
hard to tackle these three things so
don't do this okay it's simple
don't write pipe lines like this instead
what you want to do is come up with some
abstraction some framework which can
enable you to focus on machine learning
and not focus on these stupid problems
that you don't want to deal with if you
saw the previous talk by the the stripe
guys there's an open source tool called
Luigi look into Luigi but here today I'm
going to talk about facebook's solution
to this problem and hopefully you can
learn from our mistakes in our design so
there are three kinds of problems that
data form is meant to to solve and it
solves them in this way these form
define rethinks pipelines by introducing
three new concepts the first concept is
the task so that's something that has a
dot execute method it just does
something I don't care what it is but it
can run itself
the second thing data form introduces is
dependencies so tasks can depend on each
other in this way we're building a
dependency graph it's an acyclic graph
otherwise things will never start and
then the third thing that data swarm
realizes is something that machine
learning data scientists want is
scheduling so you want to be able to
have a snapshot of your graph around
every single day and maybe there's some
kind of implicit self dependency when
you have things being scheduled this way
so as you'll find out though that data
swarm does not
data storm takes a declarative approach
to defining this dependency graph and I
think Burke put it in a really good way
data swim in its heart is a dependency
graph description language so the code
that you'll see is not actually code
that runs to completion and does
anything rather it just defines what you
want to do and it's up to data swarm and
data forms infrastructure to actually
figure out how to go about executing
your pipeline and what it is that you
want it to run so let's revisit now the
CAD shift pipeline written as a data
store pipeline ok so this is all the
code will go through it line by line so
that you can see all of the important
parts so the first thing I'm going to
talk about is this global defaults
construct so what global defaults does
is it sets default parameters for every
task that we're going to instantiate
inside of this pipeline alright does
this under the covers with a simple
magical decorator so what i'm doing here
is i'm saying that every task that i
define in this pipe on hereafter should
default to be owned by m star which is
me and it should default to have a
schedule of @ daily which is just an
alias for the cron string equivalent
that we saw before everybody understands
ADD daily not everyone understands its
jaws 0 0 star star star right so global
defaults sets default parameters for
everything in this file the second thing
we're we're gonna look at is how do we
start telling the data swarm that we
want to do some work so the way you tell
data storm you want to do work is by
creating instances of operators an
operator is something that has a dot
execute and in this case we're creating
an instance of a class called hive ql
operator what does hi ql operator do it
runs a hyper area and as such it
requires the hive query parameter and
you'll note that we assign the hive ql
operator to a variable named find calves
remember this so then the third thing to
note is how do we specify dependencies
between tasks you specify dependencies
between tasks by passing in a list to
this parameter called DEF list dep list
is short for dependency list so what you
do is you pass in a list of the other
tasks which need to be completed before
this task will begin running um you'll
note that it's not a string identifier
or anything
that is actually the object instance
itself which means you could depend on
things that are outside of your module
simply by importing them kind of handy
so you'll see in the second step we have
a new class called hive to file operator
you can guess what that one does it runs
a hive query and then dumps the results
to a txt file so we have hive query and
then file path those are those are how
you specify those two things
so you'll notice inside of our hive
query the first thing is where d s
equals date ID so d s is like convention
used at Facebook for date stamp and then
this date ID that is definitely not a
date stamp so what's going on here is
that date ID is actually a macro it's
value will be expanded at runtime to
take on the value for which this task
was scheduled this is a super powerful
concept because what it means you can do
is run your pipeline for arbitrary dates
of time right I can run the same
pipeline against yesterday's data a week
ago Stata or a year ago x' data so if I
found out there was crappy data in the
system a month ago I can rerun for all
of those steps the other macro that we
see here again there's file path equals
temp file it acts just like the temp
file module it's going to create a
temporary file which is accessible by
all of your tasks under the same name
you don't need to know where that file
ends up you you just know that it can be
accessed by all of your tasks and then
finally we have PHP operator runs a PHP
script or in this case PHP statements
and again we're saying via the DEP list
that it depends on the dump cat gifs
step so if you've been following the DEP
lists along so far you'll know that the
pipeline is going to run three steps
serially so that nothing happens out of
order and again we're assigning the PHP
operator to a variable name to post cat
gifs remember that one - okay so recap
we've got this global default construct
which is used to set default parameters
for every operator we instantiate so
user is a required parameter but we
never had to explicitly set it for any
of the operators in this file
we've created three instances of
different operators that specifies how
we want the what the pipeline should
actually do and then we've specified the
dependencies between operators so that
we can say first run fine CAD gifs
then dump them then run the PHP script
okay
so any questions so far yeah
yeah have sort of two questions number
one is you're giving us examples of how
queries do support arbitrary code
modules and second of all if the
dependency list is more than one item do
you have like a special class that
defines an aggregator from the output of
multiple items I'm not sure what you
mean about the aggregator but for the
operators themselves pretty much
anything that has a dot execute you can
do whatever you want there import any
Python library to find whatever you want
as your course step so if you have
multiple dependencies you might not I
mean you want to specify basically how
you join or otherwise aggregate the
outputs of those dependencies like how
would you go about doing that you have
an example of that I think that's really
up to how you define your pipeline the
dependency list is only for specifying
which tasks actually need to run before
how you aggregate their results is
really up to you actually I'll just keep
going and leave questions for the end um
so the first thing to note is that this
is Python code but it kind of doesn't
look a lot like Python code which is
great for non engineers if you have
never written Python before this is
something you can pick up and you could
start writing pipelines and that's good
for Facebook because we have a lot of
people who maybe aren't very familiar
with Python but there are - well wizards
the second thing to note but but at the
same time because this is regular Python
code there was nothing stopping us from
defining our operators inside of a
function or a class or a for loop and
we'll get back to this fact it in the
more complex example later but just keep
that at the back of your mind that
there's a lot more to this than meets
the eye and then the final thing to note
is that there's there's no main right no
underscore underscore main there's no
dot execute there's no dot run the
pipeline just is it exists and that's it
so that begs the question how do you
actually run this darn thing so running
the pipeline is actually delegated to a
different script we you test a pipeline
with the tester script so that's the one
we're going to talk about today so to
run the pipe
when we pass in the path to the file
that we wanted we want to run and then
we pass in the date again this date is
not the date at which the pipeline is
running but rather the date for which
it's scheduled and that gives us that
ability to shift things throughout time
if you hit enter with that command-line
what you're gonna see is some log output
like this it'll tell you what it's
executing in order it'll start executing
things one at a time and then with the
tester as as is it's just gonna print
the logs to your console so there's a
couple things to note here the first is
that all of the tasks their prefixes are
actually just the module name from where
we're imported unless the tasks prefix
right so all of our all of our tasks
were defined in di example kgf example
and that's the module name and that's
also the prefix this has the nice
property that you're not going to have
naming conflicts because the unless you
define the variable and then override it
inside of the same file you're not going
to have two separate pipelines stepping
on each other's toes the second thing to
note is that the task ID suffix that's
actually the variable name that we had
assigned inside of the inside of the
module right so we had three steps fine
cat gifs dump cat gifs post cat gifs
those were the variable names and now
they're part of the task ID so taking
the module name combined with the task
the variable name put those together and
you have the task ID itself and it's a
unique way of identifying any data storm
operator and then the final thing to
note again is we always pass in a date
so the date specifies for which context
this pipeline should be run under and
then that will go later be used by the
pipeline's when expanded as the date ID
macro or through other mechanisms
so to recap data storms primary
abstraction is the operator scheduled at
a specific date our users write Python
code which defines the pipeline and it's
actually delegated to these driver
scripts to actually run this stuff and
by doing this we can start to address
all of those problems that we originally
mentioned
so first let's revisit fault tolerance
so fault tolerance inside of a
this room is really straightforward you
add num retries to global defaults and
everything is going to retry three times
until it fails again because this is
just the default parameter you can
override stuff when you create an
instance at instantiation time if you
had this and ran tester locally you're
gonna see something like this if the CAD
shift step fails we're gonna sleep some
defined amount you can provide and then
we're gonna retry until we've exhausted
all of our retries selectivity is also
easy this way now that we've defined our
pipeline rather than telling us how to
run the pipeline so we've already seen
that one way to run a pipeline is just
to pass in the Python file itself and
everything will be executed respecting
dependencies but we could have passed in
a single task right because it's up to
the driver script this passing in this
command line would only load the dump
cat gifs operator and only call that
execute on that so we can avoid the
whole issue of commenting things out of
our pipeline because again the pipeline
definition is separate from the
execution context itself we can also do
fancier stuff like regular expressions
so maybe we want to only run stuff that
matches some common prefix or common
directory and we can get even more
fancier and more fancy and do stuff like
include dependencies of one single test
so this would specify a task and then
run everything that that is upstream of
it and then the other thing we mentioned
was was remoting so with datastore we
actually kind of cheat we didn't write
the system within D data swarm but
rather we use another system inside of
Facebook which is called Kronos Cronus
is actually very similar to I think it's
Airbnb they have their own tool which is
also code Chronos and what Chronos does
is it's a thrift service inside of
Facebook which lets us run arbitrary
shell commands and it lets us monitor
their monitor their progress and then
view the historical logs and things like
that
so again if you're working on a system
like this for yourself don't build it
maybe necessarily into your own data
from equivalent but rather find some
system which is good at handling
remoting for you and cheap so if you run
data swarm tester with - - remote what's
gonna happen is instead of printing the
logs to the console it's just going to
print out a URL and that URL will take
you to a dashboard where you can
actually track the progress of your
pipeline rather than try to parse the
logs all locally in this case you can
see this is launching it launches all
three of our tasks at the same time the
dependencies were registered with
Chronos now and then Chronos will take
care of running things in order because
that's how Chronos Curtis can handle
some dependencies one added side-effect
to - - remote is because you've only
specified how many retries you want to
have we can implement different retry
policies using these drivers scripts so
in this case if we have - - remote and
retries configured what's going to
happen is if a task fails
coronis will retry that that that
command on a different machine so that
means we can avoid an entire class of
failures due to hosts failure right
after you've tested your pipeline you've
run it with tests or you've run it on -
- remote IDEs and your peers think
you're doing something that actually is
useful it comes time to schedule and
scheduling is actually as simple as
checking your pipeline in for data swarm
once you check your pipeline in data
storm scheduler we'll pick up on the new
or updated files and then begin
scheduling it's pretty much that simple
and then once the tasks are scheduled we
have a UI which you can use to maintain
and disable pipelines without actually
taking out their code so once you've
checked in the cat shift pipeline you'll
see something like this the first thing
to note is the the task IDs again they
show up here and they're nested based on
dependencies so you can collapse and
expand different sections of the
dependency tree we've tried a lot of
graph based viewers you know graph is d3
all of those things so far we haven't
found anything that works better than
nested tables everything else just looks
crazy and then the second thing to note
is history
so for each task in this case my
pipeline was running fine for the last
couple days
and that makes it easy for me to tell
that we just look at the history for
each task across time but it also would
make it easy for us to identify failures
if you do perhaps identify a failure we
have a bunch of maintenance tools that
you can use from the UI for instance you
can do things like clear and restart at
instance or you can even backfill an
entire task or selection of tasks across
time because maybe you know that you
know some upstream table which you
depend on had had wonky data for last
week and you want to rerun the entire
pipeline for a week you would just go to
the UI select those tasks and then kick
off a backfill which would run in
parallel on the Khronos hosts we also
have a couple of other bells and
whistles - we have a Gantt chart view so
you can see where your pipeline is
wasting time this one's not super
interesting because it's generally a
serial pipeline we also have a
historical landing time view this was
actually recently added by one of our
customers not not a data storm dev
itself and what this will do is show the
tasks arrival times for each step in
your pipeline across time and what that
can let you do is it can let you
identify places which which need
improvement and then also see did your
perf actually lead to an improvement or
maybe a regression okay so earlier on I
met I mentioned data swarm the pipeline
in the cat shift pipeline is pretty
simple right so now let's talk about the
start to hint at the full power of data
Swan and so to do that we're gonna do
another example in this case we're gonna
build a service to replicate hive tables
into my sequel but here's the gotcha the
hive tables need to be specified not
from data swarm Python code we want them
to be specified by people who have never
touched Python in their life and we want
them to be able to provide the query
from a UI write so they're they're not
not going to type any code and they need
to specify the hive query which is going
to be run and then loaded into my sequel
so how would we do that in datastore
so again the big advantage is data swarm
is regular Python code so you can start
to write functions
which generate pipelines rather than
write them manually so here I've defined
a two-step pipeline which is going to be
returned from a function called get
replication pipeline so get replication
pipeline accepts a table name it will
create and then it will create to step
to stage pipeline where the stages are
serial the first one is create so we're
gonna run some my sequel query which
will create the table and then replicate
which would actually run some hive hype
to my sequel stage but we said the whole
thing needs to be specified from the UI
right and here I've hard coded my sequel
query and - II and this would totally
not work in a general sense well that's
no problem because the hive query and my
sequel query themselves could have been
returned from another function and maybe
that function imported the hive meta
story API looked at the schema of the
table or parse the query that was about
to be run and then generated dynamically
the query that's actually meant to load
this table from hive into my sequel
putting it all together putting it all
together again we're gonna read the list
of tables to be replicated and we can do
that again from a function which is
maybe actually talking to a back-end DB
which was populated by the UI and then
we're going to generate the pipeline for
each table that we want to replicate so
these are some toy examples in the real
world that data storm at Facebook data
swarm runs a virtual data store runs
virtually every batch pipe batch
processing pipeline that we have and
that does accumulate to processing
nearly 300 petabytes of data for a few
examples we have a bunch of these
replication services they're obviously
more complex than a two-stage pipeline
but you get the gist we have tons of
people using them for machine learning
we have a a B testing framework called
deltoid which was built entirely inside
of data swarm where the experiments
themselves are defined in a UI and data
storm constructs an a/b test from the UI
rather than having people write code and
then finally it's used by a bunch of
different organizations pretty much all
of them ðï adds search security you name
it
so the key takeaways I hope you get from
this talk since data's form is not open
source is don't try maybe you you need
to build a tool like data the data swarm
yourself but at the same time just
realize that you don't have to put up
with the pains of managing a pipeline
execution service there are tools like
Luigi that exists which you should
consider but don't put up with the pain
find something that works for your team
and use it it's really that simple the
way we do that at Facebook is by taking
the whole pipeline problem in
abstracting it into three separate
concepts the tasks the dependencies and
then schedules and rather than using
Python as an execution context we just
use it as our definition language yeah
so with with data storm we found that
our data scientists really can spend all
of their days working on on data science
it's crazy
thank you
any questions summons so if I understood
correctly you have basically a cluster
operating system something similar to
maybe slurm or some good engine or DBS
but you have a Python interface and you
have a web UI that you can use and it
allows you to send many of those and
handle dependencies yes which a lot of
those systems do but one thing that I
haven't seen in those is your ability to
try some of those tasks in case they
fail so did I catch this correctly is
there something else that there's those
systems not have that you do have I'm
not I'm not entirely familiar with those
systems but I can tell you what Chronos
does so Cronus is a system it's a pool
of machines which are managed by a
scheduler and what you can submit to
Cronus you submit to Kronos via a thrift
interface a job definition which is
really just a command line that command
line accepts parameters so you can use
the same job but maybe tweak it just a
little bit and then Cronus also does
support the notion of dependencies
between jobs so the way data swarm would
work in that previous example when you
run tests or it's gonna submit three
separate jobs and register within Cronus
the dependencies between them and then
Kronos by default out of the box and
always will hat will do retries across
different machines so I was curious for
the sort of the dependencies they have
these working working sets that they
output let's say that they up a working
set to two or three machines and then
all of those machines fail so you want
to retry the tasks on a separate machine
how do you handle the problem of data
locality ah so we we don't make any data
local ever that's what we do the Cronus
machines I think they're like local disk
is like one terabyte which for some
people like if just two of their
pipelines around on the same machine it
would be totally hosed so we use we use
we use networks storage mounted via NFS
so like things like
Napper Gluster never local uh with the
caveat you could do local if it was all
within the same task but across tasks we
require you to use something that's
networks yeah I'll just I'll just repeat
it sure so the question was on the GUI
there's uh this depends on on past
column so depends on past is just like
an extra parameter I didn't go over all
of them which says whether a task has
that self dependency so in some
pipelines like if you depend on
yesterday's data you obviously can't run
today's pipeline today's version of that
pipeline until yesterday's has completed
so that basically means you want to halt
all execution until all previous runs
have succeeded but for other pipelines
maybe it doesn't matter in which case
you just want to drive through failures
and you would set depends on past equals
false
I don't depend on past versions of
myself yeah so the other question was by
default do we save data or overwrite we
highly highly highly recommend everybody
always do overwrite because it's item
potent if you do insert into your gonna
have a bad dime that's it's as simple as
that
yeah so just to make sure that I
understood correctly you like your users
to find their own operators besides the
built-in operators correct so we we have
a core set of operators that just makes
sense right - well my sequel Oracle like
every data source Under the Sun at
Facebook anyway we have an operator for
that we have one to like load data
between each other and then we have
stuff for running scripts yeah and those
the core data StormTeam we manage and
make sure that people don't do stupid
things or like unexpected things but
yeah all you really need to do is
subclass base operator and then
implement your own execute method so I
mean given that your users may create
their own operator can they install
external packages within those operators
and how do you manage that yeah
especially if machines fail you know you
need to install good that's a good
question so Burke mentioned we at
Facebook we have this build system for
Python and basically what it what it
boils down to is you have a list of
things other modules which should be
installed and then what we deploy to all
of our hosts is is like a
self-extracting shell script basically
which has all of your dependencies that
being said it's still somewhat of an
open problem we're looking to make it
easier for people to like hook in
dependencies that would they want to use
without them being distributed by
default because maybe they you know
they're their dependencies don't make
sense for everybody and for that we
we're still exploring some options that
are basically going to do something
along the lines of like downloading a
package adding it to sis path and LD
library path and then like try to remove
them secretly between pipelines but yeah
how how many of those jobs can you
handle like this is it is it actually
like can you handle hundred thousands of
jobs even small ones that are scraping
something or doing something and if you
do if what happens in case of a mistake
someone presses the button says oh no I
need to delete all of those because I
added I had to add this line like do you
have any scripts that can delete them
and start again and sure so how many can
we handle deenis worms the scheduler
itself is actually a dispatcher it just
needs to figure out what's eligible to
run and then Cronos itself is written in
Java and it can handle I think it runs
like on the order of like millions of
jobs per day I don't know it's a lot as
your question on like what if I
accidentally launched off a bunch of
jobs funny story
I once was on call for our team and this
one guy who's like a really big customer
of ours kicked off a backfill starting
in not 2013 but 2012
and Cronus happily accepted you know his
is twice as much as he had expected so
we have a whole bunch of tools for like
killing off stuff in parallel we have a
bunch of other like extra tools which
can do things like restart all furnace
jobs which failed with this in their log
message for like more bizarre failure
scenarios but yeah we basically have
separated data swarm the scheduler is
really just a dispatcher and then all
the the work of finding a free host
we've delegated to Kronos and Kronos
does that you know with timers and
things in Java alright let's thank our
speaker and get ready for the keynote
thank you